how's that I haven't started yet
ladies and gentlemen brothers and
sisters comrades and friends it's very
good to see so many people investing the
campus of UCLA for such a wonderful fair
as has been brought us by Steve
Wasserman my old friend and the LA Times
Book Review and his collaborators but I
must say it's very depressing to see
this number of people coming to a
discussion on the nation's capital I
always hope for ill attended meetings on
this subject myself whenever I read
people saying that public cynicism is so
great that we may be in real trouble
nobody likes the system nobody trusts
the politicians nobody votes I think we
would really only be in trouble if that
was not served so signs of enthusiasm
are very much deplored I think I speak
for us all
yeah and we'll it's our job to dispel
any illusions you may have brought along
with you there are only very few I've
been in Washington now 16 years I've
picked up only a very few basic Maxim's
my name is Christopher Hitchens I'll be
your moderator today I've never been a
moderator before I suppose that may be
why I was asked to be a moderator this
time I all moderate this event which
I've garnered in that period and would
share with you like to share with you
some of them of my have stone some of
them were from Mike Kinsley some of them
are from anonymous they are the scandal
in Washington is never what is illegal
the scandal is always what's legal
already don't believe anything until
it's been officially denied at least
three times that one is that that one
was Izzy stone I keep that one above my
typewriter pinned up you never know on
what page of the Washington Post are
great hometown newspaper you never know
on what page you will find the page one
story
and if you want a friend within the
Beltway get a dog we have a canine
expert in fact here today partly for
this reason I think you're very well
served if I may say so by your panelists
reading from the end towards me Arianna
Huffington who I have known as Ariana
Stetson applause an estas novelist -
Arianna Huffington f scott Fitzgerald
was never more wrong I've sometimes
thought than when he said there are no
second acts in American lives Arianna is
here I think we might say to dispute
that proposition in the middle we have
Larry bannout whose book American Hero
I'm sure a lot of you've read in whose
movie I was lucky very lucky to see one
of the very few good things that's come
to me for living in Washington in the
recent past was the ability good fortune
to go to the the premiere of wag the dog
and to get an advance jump
a canine jump if you will on what was to
come and then right next to me which
makes which puts me in the in I think
this is not invidious to say in the
Placid honor and place of honor Paul
Krassner I can't tell you what he's
meant to me I when we spoke last the
last time we met which was at the Abbie
Hoffman memorial meeting in New York I
wasn't able to tell him I was too
tongue-tied but for those of us who
remember back to the that crucial year
1964 and reading the realist and reading
the unpublished chapter from the William
Manchester book on the Kennedy
assassination and finding out that it
was all true by Lyndon Johnson and the
special cranial surgery and the and the
new passages for penetration well I can
only say I'm lost still but I think back
on it I've I've heard people say that
they think it's not true so I'm kind of
a put on the word Terry Sullivan was
once mentioned I think certain things
are just morally true okay speaking of
new avenues of penetration and so forth
I suppose the if you want a conception
of the serial in Washington the most
recent one I'd be able to offer you
would be just remember because memory is
short remember the time that this
president fired his own personally
chosen female Surgeon General Joycelyn
elders
do you remember why he fired him do you
- so I don't have to embarrass the
c-span audience by saying that it was
for talking about hand jobs in public
you're on TV by the way ladies and
gentleman now for not being from not
being able to mention as Surgeon General
the humble unassuming hand job the same
president forcing the entire country to
say [ __ ] in front of their families
it seems to me seems it seems to me to
be in here I want to make a straight
bipartisan point progress of a kind very
well that we have a fantastic mixture of
of age experience and brains and beauty
to go on and for that reason I lost
Paul's start I'm going to ask them all
to be pungent and brisk because I know
you will have questions and here we go
I've never been referred to as a brazen
beauty for thank you very much well I
think that Steve Allen once said that
satire is tragedy plus time but what's
happened is that the rate of irreverence
has been accelerating along with
everything else and and that's
particularly been enhanced by the world
wide web so that now not only has
reality been nipping at the heels of
satire but it occasionally overtakes it
it overtook it yesterday I remember when
I was watching c-span and I saw Brian
lamb discussing the semantics of scumbag
my my left and right lobes my brain
fused at that moment is but what's been
happening is that or that all of this
scandal has served as America's glass
nose to it which is Russian for truth
and I just want to quote one little
thing from his book called the Congress
of clowns and other Russian circus acts
by Joel Sir Schechter in which he writes
and this was at the time of glass toast
and it's what's happening in America
today in Leningrad the highly regarded
humorist Sam yawn Altaf said that he has
moved from satire to non topical more
Universal fiction in his recent writing
because newspaper reporters are now
providing the public with the news of
dissent that only satire could convey
previously and it's true I saw on ABC
News in the evening news there was the
anchor Peter Jennings and Cokie Roberts
was in Washington in the field and
Jennings said to her Cokie what do you
think this
we'll be tomorrow now I don't want to
seem old-fashioned but I remember a time
when the news was reporting what had
happened rather than asking journalists
to predict what the propaganda would be
the next day but it's not just the news
people that do that it's also the people
in the news all mostly inadvertently I
let me read this to you because I want
to get it the exact quote because this
was not aligned from Jay Leno or David
Letterman or Conan O'Brien but this was
from Bernard Lewinsky Monica Lewinsky's
father who had this to say in defense of
his daughter quote she's a very smart
intelligent beautiful girl who's going
to go places and unfortunately she's
taking her licks but you know he's he's
an oncologist people specialize so one
other little sentence I want to read
here because it makes the point how how
satire and reality the line between them
is is getting so blurred that even I as
an editor of a publication which never
labels something as satire or reality
because I don't want to deprive readers
the pleasure of discerning for
themselves whether something is true or
or a satirical extension of the truth so
a fella in Portland Oregon who has who's
really the revolutionary voice they have
a publication called weapon and it's
it's posted on 500 telephone poles
throughout the city and but it's very
radical and he wrote a piece for me on
the private prison system and it was a
very satirical piece but mixed with
truth and there was one thing where he
refers to here he says in fact a slavery
because there is a form of slavery in
the prison now with prison labor
you know those telecommuter calls we get
a you know his problem murder in a Cell
on his cell phone
so he so he writes here these lower
production costs trickle down to the
consumer cheaper labor means lower
prices at the supermarket and more
affordable cars given the reliable
increase in the crime rate rate we could
staff more and more industry with
cost-effective prison labor America
returned to a slave economy in which
criminals are bought and sold providing
a life of luxury and idle pleasure for
the victims and the obedient law-abiding
people in fact slavery was never
outlawed in the United States the 13th
article of the Constitution states
neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude except as punishment for a
crime shall exist within the United
States I thought what a brilliant piece
of satire and then I checked and that is
the 13th article so there are copies of
this issue with the realist help
yourself there'll be at both ends as you
leave just one more final point which is
that what passes for political satire
today is really name-calling and easy
references easy reference humor so even
during the last campaign you know always
there were sex and Diet jokes about Bill
Clinton and there were ageist and temper
jokes about Bob Dole but it never got to
the issues and it applies it's not just
Washington political satire applies to
the laws that are passed in order for
people to maintain power and popularity
and so you know so therefore Bill
Clinton who is so charming you forget
that underneath the charm is this guy
who went to the execution of a mentally
[ __ ] prisoner on his way to becoming
president and who now mr. compassion is
against medical marijuana you know it's
sort of I feel your pain I just don't
want to help relieve it and so so
whenever you see on the late-night talk
shows and and there's somebody doing the
joke about Robert Downey what they're
doing is they're making the victim the
target of the satire and instead of
instead of doing an easy reference joke
about Robert Downey they
they could attack the laws that make an
addiction a crime and and that's the sad
part of it
arianna we're in your hands
well I bring you news from last night's
White House Correspondents Dinner in
Washington about just how dead political
satire is after all this is the one
occasion every year when official
Washington comes together to secure each
other the president is supposed to
secure the fourth state the for Thursday
to secure the president well last night
the president did his job pretty well as
he always does and those occasions
deflecting criticism from himself
through humor the Fourth Estate was so
tame so contemptible that he actually
hired a comedian who said to them
apparently when he was hired that he
knows nothing about politics he does not
follow politics at which point they
offered to double his fee and he
proceeded to give us basically a Las
Vegas stand-up act about his twins and
his life and the fact that once you have
twins you only have sex every three
months and that kind of stuff that would
have been fine you know in a Las Vegas
show but not on the one occasion once a
year when you're supposed to say
something satirical about the president
the Washington establishment is
terrified at the parties afterwards
everybody was saying how relieved they
were that nobody said anything to
embarrass the president I mean that's
what this occasion has been about for
years and basically the bottom line is
at the state of ridicule the state of
late-night Monica jokes on Leno
Letterman is very healthy I would say
it's about as healthy as the president's
blood flow on the on the other hand the
state of satire is about as healthy as
the blood flow of let's say Warren
Christopher so what do we do basically
we're living in an entirely surrealistic
and American politics I just discovered
yesterday that the Library of Congress
has classified my book greetings from
the Lincoln Bedroom as current American
history
which one you consider that it takes
place over a fantasy weekend in the
White House with socks the cat being my
guide and my deep throat the Vice
President being a talking statue and the
president and the speaker reaching a
historic bipartisan agreement in the hot
tub that oral sex is not adultery you
wonder if this is current American
history
what is satire and the reason why I say
that satire is absolutely dead is that
satire traditionally has been fueled by
passionate belief but the desire to
change the world and there is a quote
actually from Paul Krassner that I use a
lot so I'm going to quote it in his
presence when he said that sometimes
humor is just a way of calling attention
to the contradictions or the hypocrisy
that's going on officially that's the
function of humor it can alter your
reality and that's what we don't have
enough of we basically have an a reality
that is completely stagnant politically
we have two political parties but one
political class which is why
increasingly you have people of the left
and right coming together looking for
new alliances and which is why I am in
this my seventh book I turned to satire
because really there's no other way for
me to approach American politics Pauling
and pollsters have basically ruined
politics and one of the things that we
can actually do one of the small acts of
civil disobedience is for all of you
here to hang up on pollsters next time
they call you and if you don't have the
courage to do that just hang up on them
and then lie to them if you don't have
character cards to hang up on them
anything to contaminate the sample
yeah yeah so basically through satire as
a form of dissent is what interests me
and the more we practice it the more
likely we are to challenge the
Washington establishment and to produce
some fundamental change that is needed
because as Abraham Lincoln tells me when
he comes to visit me in the Lincoln
Bedroom very well preserved if I may say
so he tells me that leadership has
always been a risky business and
leadership has always been about moving
a nation from where it is to where it
needs to be well there is nobody who can
fit the description today because
leadership at the moment has become
simply an exercise of commissioning upon
receiving the shallow results and then
fitting them back to the American public
in this most toxic recycling and that's
leadership
no wonder over 50% of the American
people have tuned out and don't even
bother to vote and what is remarkable is
that when you remember them Columbus
Ohio town-hall meeting it just took a
few hecklers to change American foreign
policy which shows how relatively easy
it is once we stop actually simply
accepting the problem we are being fed
to create a critical mass of citizens to
change things and the final point I want
to make is that I have a sort of
all-consuming desire to lower our guffaw
threshold what I mean by that is do you
remember the good old days when we used
to laugh at Dan Quayle
well misspelling we still do but you
know what misspelling potatoe is a
trivial crime compared to what's going
on right now and he had nobody's
laughing at least not enough of us are
laughing to create a major loud belly
laugh for example when in Africa the
president was asked why he invoked
executive privilege and he replied that
he didn't know anything about it he just
read about it in the morning papers
what why didn't the press called the foe
why didn't they laugh so harder they had
tears in their eyes that they couldn't
even write his statement down
instead like the sheep that the American
media have become they wrote it down and
moved on off when Newt Gingrich because
I'm an equal-opportunity offender when
Newt Gingrich was talking to Brian LOM
and told him in book notes that he's
really given up largely the sunday shows
because they're full of self-important
people I mean self-importance is the
man's distinguishing characteristic
after all he was the one who said I have
an overweening ambition I want to shift
the planet and I'm doing it and yet
nobody laughed so pleased as the
beginning to sort of resurrect in
political satire lower yoga for
threshold laughs at the expense of our
political leaders of both parties hang
up on pollsters and begin to demand more
political satire based on passionate
conviction instead of just late-night
easy
mónica jokes and I just like to end with
a late-night easy Monica joke which is
that when I arrived at the White House
which is very much like Disneyland
outside the Lincoln Bedroom I saw a sign
that said you have to be this high to
ride the president
the first opera Polly Thank You Ariana
they say if you live that was Greek
you're wondering I'm wearing the cover
of my book which Abbie Hoffman of afford
for you to have the right to do that's
true and they say and they say if you
live long enough everything will in the
end happen to you now
Arianna and I could link arms with the
absent Mario Savio and say put your
bodies on the gears throw them on the
levers try and stop the machine try and
gum up the machine otherwise what she'll
get is another person who was a great
hero of my youth Tom Lehrer whose songs
I was listening to at the same time
that's learning to read the realist oh
I'm sorry
of Tom Lehrer who I'm sure many of you
remember as a song Smith who I was
that's why no one clap because they
couldn't hear me whose songs I was
learning to appreciate rather the same
time I was learning to read the realist
hung up his gloves remember why he
stopped writing songs there's always
someone in the audience my sub
troublemaker no actually he hung up his
gloves when Henry Kissinger won the
Nobel Prize for Peace he said I can't do
anything with this and nothing nothing
occurs to me the words won't come it was
a bad day Larry Wow
next time remind me to go first not
third I play top this yeah the press
doesn't laugh it's not what they do
I got I had my five minutes of with two
minutes or 35 seconds of fame during the
Monica Lewinsky feeding frenzy and so I
got to a bunch of interviews and I
normally try to be funny I don't know if
I'm going to do that tonight
we'll be the judge of that but anyway
and and when I was talking to press
people I just couldn't make them smile
they were just like this must be serious
you're you're talking this must be
these are the people who during during
the during the great Monica Lewinsky
opening act which stand out there in
front of the White House for hours and
we switched to them on camera and you'd
get Jane I'm standing out here in front
of the White House and as you can see
there's nothing actually happening here
but I am standing here and I will
continue to stand here and if anybody
goes in or out I will tell you about it
I will be the first one to tell you
about it and I will continue to stand
here because the White House is behind
me and this is the White House in crisis
I mean is what they do and and it really
doesn't matter what the subject is you
know they do it with the weather too we
are in a hurricane watch and we in the
press love hurricane watches because we
know that the event will happen and we
can place our camera in position so that
we can't see it happen and you all
watching it now but that's what the
press does now
what satirist does or what I learned
from Paul Krassner was you take the same
stuff and you put a new label on it
my favorite realistic was something
called soft softcore pornography of the
Month award in which Paul would take
photographs of some things that of
things that had previously appeared to
be completely innocuous and by so
labeling them transform them three that
come to mind one was a picture of a
gearshift you know in a Volkswagen and
it was a Volkswagen ad and the
Volkswagen ad said is your wife afraid
of a stick shift
then there was a bakery ad which had a
picture of a curl of a crawler which
looked once Paul put his label on it
exactly like female genital organs and
the third was a picture of Ronald Reagan
on holding a young boy's head in his
hands and the boy was about oh I guess
hi to Monica Lewinsky if she were on her
knees anyway what we've learned what
we've learned from the recent events in
in Washington in the Monica Lewinsky
case is in fact there are still two
parties in America they are the pro-sex
party and the anti sex party now this is
in fact true the the we are in the era
of the soft machine and in the era of
the soft machine consumerism rules and
pollsters rule and Newt Gingrich and
Bill Clinton agree on the economy on war
on the the the budget on debt so all
that's left the only issues the americas
disagree on are sex issues and they are
abortion gay rights women's rights
welfare and affirmative action civil
rights civil rights in this country
being a sexual issue and I'm not going
to touch that one but it is now the good
news is it good news is that the pro sex
party seems to have won and on that note
I think we're gonna like I'm gonna get
out of this and and turn this over to
questions for the moderator we already
have a question yeah first I want to say
that the way to tell softcore
pornography was that it would give a man
a soft on okay
and a soft on can be defined as
something that you know it when you see
it in this case you know when you won't
ladies and gentlemen sorry I just wanted
to point out to Arianna that as to the
idea of hanging up on pollsters they've
already taken a poll on that and found
that it wouldn't work and then what one
other point which is I was very much
influenced by Lenny Bruce who said that
he was part of everything that he
indicted so I think it's important for
satirist not to separate themselves and
make themselves superior to the people
they criticize and here we are the enemy
and in our enemy well at least we're not
peerless but I but you know I do I I was
at Ariana's talk this afternoon where I
mean I'm sure I read somewhere in her
column about the evils of some kind of
illegal wiretapping and yet she said
that she had snooped on her
eight-year-old daughters diary and I I
wonder how you would justify that in an
age where you value privacy so much
actually not only would I justified but
I would highly recommend it I think you
should all snoop in your children's
bedrooms after they fall asleep my
children are eight and six and by
snooping in my oldest daughters diary I
found what she had written about the
presidential sex scandal she was trying
to make sense of it and she had numbered
her responses one the president is
flattering she created that work between
philandering and floundering
to the president and Monica had sex
params we think which was the
journalistic equivalent of allegedly and
it went on like that three four and when
I finished reading it part of me wanted
to sit down and cry at the fact that we
had intruded in our children's minds at
an early age all those concepts and the
other part of me of course laughed but
what can you do when you really have to
turn off CNN when your kids walk into
the room and when increasingly Cokie
Roberts is sounding like dr. Ruth sir
teach him at a young age how to remove a
semen stain so they don't learn it on
the street we also had the we also had
to ask the president nd the other day
was that a V chip in his pocket or was
he just pleased to see it now look it's
obvious already that we have a great
deal more to fear than fear itself in
this room and it's your turn ladies
gentlemen to join the feast of reason
and the flow of soul there are
microphones they won't make you any
louder but they do help c-span very much
so if you can find a microphone to ask
your question that would be grant and
anyone who's boring or tedious will be
cut off without a component you'll know
it when you hear it on your comment on
the pollsters I think there's something
even more insidious these damned focus
groups whose purpose is to get people to
vote with their gonads rather than their
intellects and they're succeeding yes in
fact did you know that the cover
photograph of Newt Gingrich in his new
book was focus group tested to make sure
he wore the right things and make sure
that his approval rating state right
above those of the Unabomber so
I I completely agree with you and I
treat focus groups and palling a with
the same kind of contempt and when you
hear pulsed well you hear politicians
increasingly say we did a poll on that
and that's why we're going with that
issue you realize that posters are
running American politics and what Paul
said about how many people are already
hanging up on pollsters you know it's
true that the dirty little secret of
polling is that of those called forty
percent are not there you get voicemail
or answering machines of those reached
35 to 40 percent refused to talk to
posters so already basically the only
people being polled
are lonely bored Americans who want to
find somebody to talk to and that
representative sample I'm sorry you know
I think that's a shallow cheap knee-jerk
reaction and I'm sincere about this
question no I mean you know I mean focus
groups and polling and all this stuff
was developed by consumer market
researchers right and they have brought
us better cars more appealing cigarettes
more more stylish clothes and a higher
level of you know consumer existence and
all they really do is what democracy is
supposed to do is bring the consumers
the politics they want and that's a good
thing
in fact I understand in the year 2000
the election the booths will not have
the names of the candidates just the
names of the poll that you trust the
most Gallup you CNN and you just check
the one that you trust the most
it is voting in the passive voice now
it's it leads to virtual politics and
such elections and it's interesting you
never get run up and asked do you think
that our in Greenspan's control of the
federal reserve's money supply is too
tight
they don't trust you with the answer to
a question like that it's all do you
think well actually the Los Angeles
Times once I think set of hard to
emulate standard question by asking if
they thought Ronald Reagan's colon
cancer would or would not recur
might recur would recur quite soon no
was banished and so answers solemnly
given and taken and printed on the front
page of the paper
whose brother Mike don't look at me if
you want to ask a question of let's
follow the microphone okay um I will
show his hello can you get yes um I was
wondering in reflecting on on your
remarks about satire and the fall of
satire and that sort of thing
I was wondering thinking about the
Soviet Union and people's lamentation
that with the fall of communism and the
fall some of that suffering the result
as intellectuals aren't doing so well
and and whether may be the fall of
satire in this country is partly
reflection of that the economy is doing
well and and is that such a bad trade
off
I hate that question there as a matter
of fact no Lenny Bruce was a great
success at a time when everyone was
talking about nothing but consumerism
and boom and America the the preeminence
so no I don't think that's necessarily
any correlation between narcotized
society and all I mean I mean say
narcotized in the wrong way actually you
know actually and it was a great success
actually but I mean I mean was great
success in terms of his influence but at
the time both financially and publicly
he was like I don't know a minor
character that was known to not that
many people he's somebody who's legend
has grown over the years so Lenny Bruce
in his own time was more famous for his
trials and his stand-up we're not
challenging the assumption that things
are going well in fact one of the great
bipartisan frauds of modern times is
that assumption you turn on the Sunday
morning shows and Republicans and
Democrats all start with the premise
that this is a great time and then you
look a little deeper and you see that
effectively America has become two
nations and the good economic times are
influencing and affecting the one nation
and the entire political conversation is
about the one nation and the second
nation the other nation of the inner
cities and the crumbling public schools
and the super predators and the gangs
and the violence is basically completely
out of the public debate like never
before my god she's become a communist
and it's because they used a stock
market as the barometer when stocks go
up because people are being downsized so
that means more profits so you know it's
just our national purpose is greed and
so as the stock holders are as guilty as
Alan Greenspan Arianna Huffington
mentioned that the media are like sheep
and not questioning Clinton a little bit
closer his comments in Africa and I
actually saw part of the White House
Correspondents Dinner on c-span it was
it last night I don't know why I was
just enthralled by it for whatever
reason and I was really struck by the
fact that you know here you have this
meshing of political figures media and
celebrities all in this one place and it
really doesn't seem very strange to me
that they're not pressing Clinton on
these things when they're schmoozing
together I mean they're not and they're
like buddies how are you expecting the
media to be the subjective source when
really they're friends with each other
and you really don't want to push your
buddies to do you know to say something
that makes them uncomfortable so you
know how do you explain that well you're
right about that but even so say last
year the year before with Al Franken and
others being the entertainment of these
dinners you had more biting political
satire this is the first year in my
experience when you had none absolutely
zero and that's I think very significant
because the media somehow in a sense
considered the state of the present at
the moment still fragile we don't know
what's going to happen there is still an
uncertainty there and nobody wants to
rock the boat there is such a an
incumbency protection racket in
Washington between the media the
Congress and the presidency and nobody
wants to do anything which would be
remotely biting and yet the essence of
satire is that it has to touch a raw
nerve that's why I really want to do the
show that I'm calling eat the press too
did to expose the way and news and
entertainment has have have basically
merged I mean
Harish here just downloaded from his
satellite Tom brocco who had to go away
for the weekend and recording the
announcement of Frank Sinatra's death
just in case it happened and it is
really a scary thing to watch to have
Tom brocco with this more commotion this
kind of voice a major voice of the
century has passed and moving on like
that and the man is still alive as far
as I know not because a lot of us
haven't tried writing his obituary there
actually there was also download wasn't
there recently of dan Rather covering
the first bombs on Baghdad which must
have been perfect no I loved that I
wanted that to run no offense to the
Iraqi people I'm sorry
there was a download by no we don't we
don't do repeats Oh you have to listen
person who has another question
yeah hasn't this concept the political
correctness really heard said Terry you
can't say anything about anybody anymore
they'll sue you oh yes we can
would you like to say something about
somebody that would be
well if you're gonna do it in fiction as
which is my thing I write I write
fiction you put it you take for example
a politically incorrect joke about women
as I did joke that happen to love but I
knew that I could as the narrator
couldn't say it so I had George Bush say
it well the other way you can do it is
really by translating what politicians
are saying into English and in the
Lincoln Bedroom I created a character
which is a talking television with a BS
chip which is which is really much more
needed than the v-- chip and the and
that television translates everything
that politicians are saying it's called
closed captioning for the ethically
impaired and you can read the entire
State of the Union address translated
through my television I I think it's a
matter of just giving form to to what
already exists so for example when :
Powell who was the first African
American to become the head of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff and he came out against
gays in the military
so I would hold an imaginary dialogue
with Colin Powell and say general why
don't you say that you don't want gays
in the military because it would make
the other men in the barracks feel
uncomfortable but isn't that what they
once said about blacks in the military
and then Colin Powell answered yes but
we never told anybody we were black
that was the beginning of the Don't Ask
Don't Tell policy and I was about to
saying and it wasn't kosher to ask
either who else
you were familiar with a Canadian
program called newsroom on KCET that I
think is doing a better job of spoofing
the media than any American show I've
seen it's Friday nights from 10:00 to
11:00 there's a question flushing with
disqualification now it will take it
recent Canadian satirical broadcasting
north of the border satire well I think
it was on the same time in South Park so
but the larger point of the question is
that the English and maybe the Canadians
are much better at this stuff than the
Americans that's not true knocking me
all the time I mean I just lived in
England for three years what are you
merliss people I mean I mean this is a
country where I don't think anybody's
had sex sober this is not America
England this is the only man who was so
far entirely equated satire with sex I'd
like to know more about his sex life but
in the meantime I lived in England for
12 years
during the time of that was the week
that was never charged to drop up I was
told I know Wow and you never touched a
drop I was still
on every name but and that's where I met
Greece but we won't talk about that the
point is that there is something about
political satire niggles in law to offer
political invective I mean when you have
congressman Burton calling the president
a scumbag I am NOT a scumbag the
political affective of this rally
against Gladstone when he said that if
Gladstone Falls in the terms that will
be a calamity if they pull him out that
will be a catastrophe I was there for
the inhaling by the way I keep meaning
to share this with you two
the the the then student not even
governor Linton of course has always
been allergic to smoke and so naturally
he's never inhaled anything at all but
marijuana was then used to be baked into
brownies and cookies and a mainline with
both hands in mass quantities but he
didn't it was the most cleverly lawyer
reply that he could ever possibly have
given it it's funny that the one that he
spent most time polishing a lying reply
was the one that got him into most
trouble because there are still people
and let's celebrate the fact who can
spot a phony at ten feet well you know
we're all assuming that he's lying these
days and I I try to have an open mind
you know it's not like the case of
Kathleen Willey or Paula Jones where one
says yes and the other denies it so one
of them is lying but in in the case of
Monica Lewinsky both Clinton and Monica
deny it
now what is the possibility that they're
both telling the truth zero well
no but you have to remain open-minded
now you remember that statement that's
exactly what they said to all the
intellectuals who visited the Soviet
Union and they were shown the Potemkin
villages and when they were hearing
about the torture going on in the gulag
archipelago they were told you got to
keep an open mind you haven't sinned
with your own eyes keeping an open mind
has been the great disaster in the 20th
century in the way you're describing it
well but just suppose just take the
hyper because after all Dick Morris was
in on the White House it was he who
suggested that Clinton get a dog named
buddy I think it was the original name
was photo-op it was Dick Morris who
suggested that Hillary and Bill dance on
the beach without music and it was Dick
Morris who suggested that he said
hypothetically if the rumor were true
that Hillary Clinton is a lesbian then
it would make it understandable that
bill has to seek his outlets elsewhere
now suppose that would suppose that
Monica came to the White House 37 times
not for Bill but for Hillary
so they're both they're both telling the
truth and denying it
and he's being a devoted husband by also
taking the fall for her it was also it
was also Dick Morris who was author of
this stunning bestseller men are from
Mars Women are from the Yellow Pages oh
that's right next to Monica's biography
going down in history and the difference
between and the difference between the
leader of the free world and the Titanic
is only 300 women went down on the
Titanic okay but it took a lot longer
you know I've heard literally there was
a band playing hundreds and hundreds of
jokes about that because I mean what
happens now is because of the internet
and because of fax is because of shock
jocks on radio the time that even while
a tragedy is occurring such as the fire
at Waco there are already jokes about
that the Branch Davidians you could get
them in regular or crispy while it was
going on so so that what happens is
there's a kind of dehumanization of
where as people look at the news only as
setups for their material rather than
examining the horror behind it and so
it's just part of the MTV attention span
what would the conflict no contradiction
next a contradiction is not to things
said by two different people
the contradiction because there's the
difference between ridicule and satire
there is the difference between
late-night Jay Leno jokes in real satire
of the kind that Jonathan Swift and Mark
Twain and Aristophanes wrote which is
rooted in conviction I mean that's the
difference but the point is I've been
told by professors of literature who
have used Jonathan Swift's modest
proposal in their classes and the
students have been so jaded from what
what they've seen that they thought that
that was a true story and wanted to know
only the details about eating the Irish
babies you know tell us more that wasn't
that was true of a lot of the original
English audience yeah yeah I think as
with Jeff Oh ma'am do be very patient
you can hear this okay
satire depends left of content you have
a little bit of time to get to content
to get to satire as opposed to mild
mannered humor and by the way satire
people's be afraid of satire I just
heard Larry Gelbart say that when he was
opening what is it city of dreams and
was all ready to go open and Broadway
there Schubert said they looked at his
press package so you're not calling that
a comedy okay comedy now is dangerous
and that isn't even really telling
anybody anything but it occurs to me
that if the media is on its knees not
just Monica Lewinsky but the media as
its collapsed on its knees in the last
20 years at the same time we have
nobody's reading anymore maybe that's
the way we're going to get to a free
press again because if the amount of
people who read shrink to a tiny elite
we could probably get a free press again
because it won't upset anybody
was that a question and was it a
question at a book fair can bad satire
be successfully satirized and has it
ever Hemingway
Hemingway we're done there's no
contradiction in the conversation it
worked before keep trying we got a live
one
best behavior ladies and gentlemen
nothing obvious I'm wondering this is on
I'm wondering what direct impacts you've
seen your satire have on policy or
opinion making and if you can give a few
examples yeah the very worthy question
it's an excellent question I am told a
serious fraud question not reliably that
at when they were ready to go and start
Gulf War two somebody said well we can't
do that they'll think it's wagging the
dog and and and my mother was really
impressed by that but also at the
intersection of satire and dissent you
have the Columbus Ohio town hall meeting
where you had madlyn Albright and the
Secretary of Defense arriving there with
her talking points thinking they were
just going to feed that same problem to
the people and just a dozen hecklers
made mincemeat of them ridiculed them
humiliated them and changed American
foreign policy so it just shows how few
people it really takes just this
critical mass of people to turn things
around yeah and I waited for those hacks
like verge on others to say which they
did in the end through gritted teeth
well it shows what a vibrant democracy
I thought I wonder how long it'll be
till I have another such vibrant
exercise I think we I also think we
probably haven't done enough honor to
the custard pie international I see
someone knows what I mean the practical
satire of imploding pies into the faces
of men like gates in order to say a word
in their defense practice do they need
defense right now okay we'll press on
we're running low on time approaching
the last five minutes so pungent
thrusting in question space he that
Fitzgerald was wrong because there are
indeed second acts in American life and
there Ariane is a great example of one
because I seem to relate I already said
that I seem to recall a few years ago
that she and her husband spent about
twenty six million dollars right I stand
corrected
and in fact indeed on consultants and Ed
Rollins my god and political commercials
pollsters and so forth in well I learned
from he didn't do good for you and
indeed and Deanna has never believed in
education on the cheap of herself or
anyone else I'm devastating about the
phenomena Rush Limbaugh you mean
something more than Al Franken said in
Rush Limbaugh is the fat big idiot or
whatever aren't they requiring airbags
and the driver's seat as well and the
passenger seat now yeah I remember that
concert in The New Yorker of the guy
sitting in the bar and saying I never
watched Cheers so I shan't be missing
cheers I never could see the point of
liver I never knew there was anything in
my life
never saw it never got it the great
motto is always this too will pass you
know you said the world was becoming
more dehumanized I agree with you I
think the world was more humanized
eighty years ago or so when there was
more quote-unquote repression and I
think I would like to ask that question
if you you've thought about that now
that we have everything out in the open
every
is relative and quote-unquote there is
no repression we have a more dehumanized
world I think the world was much more
humanized back when Thackery in tennis
and Dickens and all the great authors
were writing at that time about real
problems in the human culture we're
talking about 1918 World War one I'm the
influenza epidemic for me you know in
mind in my logic in my logic class at
Cambridge they call this the fallacy of
the undistributed middle because you
know at the same time you had repression
and great painters repression caused the
great painters I mean there's a kind of
false correlation here and I don't think
that by bringing back repression we are
going to bring the changes about that
you seem to want to see pro-pro immoral
sexist morose ex-pro moral sexy sure you
know I think what it really means you
know I can clarify this as well this is
what moderators are for he means oral
oral and immoral oh sorry
okay who's next because we've got we've
got three minutes for anyone who wants
to be discovered as a good question on
c-span I have a question for the panel
there's been a debate in my community
recently between a group who is
promoting the concept that political
correctness is a right-wing conspiracy
what are your thoughts everything is a
right-wing conspiracy but some things
are a vast right-wing conspiracy you
know I I have been a conspiracy
researcher for many years and when the
first lady of the nation went on
national TV and said there's a vast
right-wing conspiracy I knew I could
retire I could I could pass the torch on
to Hillary so that was your normal error
moment no it was yes another time I the
left and right Louis my brains fused
it's happening more and more often sir
quick
our to the newspapers and then throws
that are going that much more team the
only tremendously
I think one of the few saving things in
the press is the autonomy given to
cartoonists the relative autonomy
including at the LA Times but a lot of
papers that's the only thing that saves
it from consensus journalism but you
still do get save my hometown paper in
Washington mr. herb block his idea of a
punchy cartoon is to have a donkey
that's how you'll know it's a Democrat
with boxing gloves confronting an
elephant that's I know it's Republican
and then that's how you could guess say
the prop might be an election on or
something like that because everything
was all taken care of so it wants
watching in the cartoon area as well and
unfortunate when cartoonists go bad
they're much harder to sack than the
ordinary hack is but also it's it's the
deadening of what passes for humor on TV
when whenever they have a laugh track I
mean it's a laugh track is the lowest
form of fascism in the sense that what
could be more individualized and you
sense of humor and yet the laugh track
is dead people laughing at I Love Lucy
who were now laughing at Seinfeld I mean
that's the only kind of immortality I
believe in the laugh track but at least
somebody mentioned Larry Gelbart before
at least mash in
they had a laugh track but in the
hospital operating rooms the left track
they never used it in the operating room
so you know a taste ism a relative
matter I will the word from the control
box is it isn't gonna get any better
than this so we'll fold now but just
exactly on time thank you all very much
for coming those of you wait wait hold
it
those of you who want an inscribed copy
of any of our books your butts should be
at the Campbell steps immediately
subsequently and get your people your
free copy of the realist as you're
peddling free copy of